[Music]  parents is a good wife get ready we are  just a few weeks away from the spinoff  the good fight the a christine baranski  chris jumbo are back to carry on the  story but it was all about gorgeous  fashion at their cover shoot for CBS  watch magazine magnificent ball guns  there's no complaining here well it sho  has some major legal drama but behind  the scenes it's all about fun they  should film us in between because they  could have a comedy reality show what  would we call that  mmm for ransburgh John Belski I like  that ya know Christine oh the good fight  will premiere February 19th on CBS and  then start streaming on CBS all access  [Music]  you